[Musique]
c'est avec vous Michel et cette édition
de l'umob de bival 3 2023 est aussi
l'occasion pour certains maires
d'interpeller sur des problématiques ce
mardi 10 octobre Philippe guigen maire
des clés sousbois a saisi dans un
courrier le président de la République
dans cette lettre le maire divers droite
interpelle Emmanuel Macron sur ses
déclarations les mécanisme des régimes
fiscaux qui régissent les collectivités
territoriales le 24 septembre dernier le
président avait déclaré lors d'une
interview sur TF1 et France 2 que
l'augmentation de la taxe foncière
n'était pas décidée par le gouvernement
mais les communes une position
inacceptable pour Philippe guigen dans
ce communiqué il y a notre réprobration
par rapport à ces propos il y a un
constat sur la situation actuelle
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus
d'autonomie financière dans les communes
alors qu'en fait c'est l'un des articles
72 de la Constitution aujourd'hui nous
sommes face à une uniquement un une
recette fiscale qui est contribuée par
les propriétaires ce qui est une pour
nous totalement inéquitable puisque si
je prends l'exemple de ma commune d'clés
sous-bois et c'est à peu près le même
exemple dans notre commune j'ai à peu
près 65% de la population qui paye
l'impôt alors que c'est 100 % et
heureusement de la population qui
bénéficie des service
public le maire des clés souo ainsi que
les 11 autres de CTIN profit de l'umop
pour engager des discussions Philippe
guigen les invite maintenant à engager
avec l'État une réforme des mécanismes
financiers toujours aux universités des
mairies une remise des trophées à
laquelle nous avons assisté ce matin
celle du prix interdépartemental de
l'innovation urbaine ce matin pour cette
5e édition les lauréat ont été
distingués pour les projets urbains
innovants des villes dans quatre
catégories parmi ell l'innovation
architecturale et paysagère ou encore
l'innovation écologique dans cette
catégorie l'agglomér
de 50 ans la ville de voisin breton ont
été récompensé pour le projet de
l'écoquartier du parc du lac également
connu comme Zac de la remise c'est la
récompense d'un travail de longue
haleine et puis ça marque aussi la
reconnaissance du soin qu'on a apporté à
à ce quartier pour qu'il soit un vrai
écoquartier donc avec beaucoup d'espac
vert avec beaucoup d'arbres avec des des
qualités environnementale
importante avec une crèche qui va être
chauffée à la géothermie par exemple
mais également des appartement chauffé
avec le système carneau avec des
qualités de d'isolation des bâtiments
pour que les habitants n'aient pas une
une note une d'électricité ou de gaz
trop importante d'autres communes
ziblinois se sont à distinguer à cher
auberganville Saint-Germain en lait ou
encore baay faisait partie des lauréat
de cette édition pour leur projet une
information maintenant qui concerne le
quartier du valfouré à montelajolie et
plus pr précisément la mairie annexe de
la ville qui va s'installer dans les
locaux de la caisse d'allocation
familiale du valfouret à deux pas de
l'ancienne mairie incendié pendant les
émeutes fin juin jusquel la mairie
annexe avait établi domicile à l'hôtel
de ville mais pour assurer un service de
proximité et réduire les déplacements
des habitants une nouvelle
délocalisation était nécessaire pour
leur quelques travaux minimes reste à
faire la mariie annexe devrait investir
ses nouveaux locaux le 2 novembre
prochain quant à la CAF elle investira
de nouveaux locaux à 800 m de là rue
Gutenberg le public sera accueilli dès
le 24 octobre on termine avec un
rendez-vous à ne pas manquer demain
jeudi à Versailles effectivement je je
m'emmène un petit peu dans dans mes
fiches je vais y arriver la ville
organise un salon dédié à l'emploi et à
l'entrepreneuriat des femmes l'objectif
faire rencontrer une trentaine
d'entreprises et d'associations qui ont
des postes à pourvoir avec des femmes à
la recherche d'un emploi en reconversion
ou en création d'entreprise ce salon est
organisé par la ville de Versailles en
collaboration avec l'Apec l'association
pour l'emploi des cadres pour l'emploi
ou encore la ville du géné concours
l'année dernière le rendez-vous avait
rassemblé 362 femmes si vous êtes
intéressé rendez-vous le octobre 9h à
l'hôtel de ville de versaill merci
Michel pour ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous êtes
témoin d'une information qui vous fait
réagir dans les Evelin n'hésitez pas la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 news